this is the image of Hong Kong that
dazzles visitors a bustling glamorous
City but underground a different reality
appears
there are many mosquitoes and bed bugs
here you see so many I'm getting fungal
infections
he has slept here for four years and
looks through rubbish bins for leftover
food in takeaway boxes official figures
released in November show the number of
people experiencing homelessness is the
highest in a decade and there's a sharp
rise in the number of women experiencing
housing insecurity
that report also said there's a need for
better services and more funds for
hostile accommodation as the situation
worsens this is a very wealthy City you
know it's extremely wealthy but one in
five at this moment are having food
insecurity they cannot afford three
meals a day
you know it's it's an amazing City where
you see the Haves and the have-nots and
it's in your face all the time
impact HK is an NGO founded in 2017. so
far they've helped around 500 people
find shelter they also welcome people
into their community centers for hot
meals and fresh clothes over 90 percent
of those individuals have no emergency
contacts they have no friend or family
member in their life and that isolation
you know plays a huge role in their you
know step towards becoming homeless he
says Emergency Shelters provided by the
government don't address the needs of
the city and are difficult for people to
access the Hong Kong government told
down to zero social workers give
assistance to those willing to accept
services in taikok Choi there are more
than 30 people sharing this underground
space it's the middle of winter here in
Hong Kong and the temperature often
drops below 10 degrees at night the
people in this underpass are preparing
for another night exposed to freezing
conditions
Alec used to be one of them he spent
almost 20 years on the streets
now I have a place to live I have food
to eat and a job I'm happy and more
cheerful now
he works in the community center
Distributing food and Essentials to
people sleeping outside helping them
through the same dark days he
experienced during his time on the
streets Jessica Washington altazira Hong
Kong